all right good evening everybody welcome
to Black Oak books I'm very happy to
introduce James rule he is the author of
privacy in peril his latest book it's a
sophisticated and troubling account of
how personal data is gathered and used
by the government and by private
industry he's a distinguished and
affiliated distinguished affiliated
scholar at the Center for the Study of
law and society here at UC Berkeley and
he's a former fellow of the Center for
Advanced Study in the behavioral
sciences at Stanford he's also the
author of private lives and public
surveillance which one the see right
mills award please join me in welcoming
James roll well thanks for that warm
introduction and thanks Michael books
for giving us the venue for this very
civilized occasion it's great for me to
come and talk a little bit about how I
got the wind in my sails to write the
book and where I started in some extent
where I came out I'm going to try not to
be redundant with any of too much of the
stuff in the middle of the book because
then you wouldn't be drawn to it anymore
but I'm be happy to let you know I'll
try to let you know kinds of questions
and very limited answers that I feel
like I ended up with and I look forward
to hearing your questions at the end
everybody I'm sure who hasn't been
sleeping through the first part of the
21st century has noticed that
information about oneself is taking on a
life of one's own and that almost
everything we do it often seems leave
some kind of trace either through credit
card slips or email email traces or
cookies that are tracked through website
and visits or the data that are left
from our cell phone uses and it's
equally apparent if you think about it
all that these data on us these these
newly concocted forms of personal
information
don't don't really live a life of their
own there
they're called into existence then
they're mobilized by big organizations
institutions of all kinds both
government institutions and private
institutions and that the it's not just
that there there is not just that
they're they're susceptible to being
scanned but they actually matter
enormously and the way to be get treated
when we when we deal with the government
when we pay our taxes when we board
airline airplanes or attempt to do so or
when we when we go to the bank or
attempt to use credit cards or other
such other such wonders of modern
economic life I don't know if you follow
the the twists and turns of the credit
industry one thing that particularly
fascinates me is that in the United
States the this is not true of all
countries you're the credit charges that
appear on your credit card statement at
the end of the month are likely to rise
that is the the rate that you pay for
the creditor you use is after rise as
other credit counts or even a single
other credit account reaches the limit
of its of its of your assigned credit so
if you if you charge your BankAmericard
or your Visa card up to the limit
without even without violating any of
the contractual rules associated with
the account you will presently find that
your the rate that you have to pay
American Express or MasterCard also
Rises because each one of each
interested party each credit card
grantor each creditor keeps close track
of the use of credit and other accounts
and you will be adjudged a greater risk
if you're using all of your credit in
one account even if your other accounts
are way down at the bottom of the limit
and even if there are no delinquencies
so we we sort of have take it for
granted in the world that we live in
that almost anything that we do in one
sector of our lives is is capable of
having repercussions and and
reverberations elsewhere some of which
we may like a lot of which we don't and
we realize it's a it's a premise of the
world that we live in it's not curve
what there is to do about it
I call these these activities that I'm
describing that the systematic
collection of personal information about
millions of people at a time and the use
of such data as a means of of
orchestrating action by institutions I
call these things mass surveillance and
and I think we've gotten so inured to
them they're almost these surveillance
activities or like the air we breathe we
don't notice them so much anymore unless
something goes wrong like a stiff rise
in our credit charges or something like
that but they do they form a basic part
of our social economic and political
landscape and they disturb people often
I think without our being able to
articulate exactly what it is that's
eating us about why we don't like these
things or why well why they why they do
to serve us and in response every every
major every large prosperous democracy
in the world
has adopted over the last generation
some kind of privacy code some set of
institutions or laws or practices that
that govern what can and cannot be done
with personal information in an effort
to protect privacy of whatever people
mean by this and often it's not at all
clear what that what that entails as so
one aim of the book and a lot of a lot
of the book is devoted this is to track
the evolution of these codes the follow
the growth of efforts in legislation and
policy to give people rights or some
measure of control over their own
information than the way it's treated by
government organizations and by private
companies and thereby to protect privacy
except that it depends what you know
nobody quite knows exactly where people
dispute what that might mean clearly the
the sheer extent of this kind of
activity that I've been describing where
large institutions gather more
information about people and use it to
to do more things to to to further and
more subtly orchestrate and control
their dealings with the people concern
these things continue to grow
a pace and so you can very well say that
in some senses by 2007 that we live in a
world compared to the beginning of the
privacy story about the late 1960s we
live in a world which has lots more
privacy regulation but arguably less
privacy
so with that disturbing thought I set
out to to do this to do this work it's
an attempt to make sense of the kind of
larger social trajectory of the growth
of surveillance as I've described it and
to try to take stock of these responses
in privacy codes and other legal and
institutional measures that are that are
aimed at protecting people from the
evils however defined of that are
associated with these activities but the
book I should say for starters isn't a
morality play it's not or an
old-fashioned melodrama where the
villains are clear from the first page
in the and the forces of righteousness
or arrayed plainly it's the ethical and
political issues involved and trying to
come up with a rationale and reason
response as to what we might do about
the proliferation of these practices I
think are not always clear like most
people who write about privacy I see it
as something of an endangered value and
I wish that there were more of it and
indeed it's probably easy for everybody
to identify uses of information about
people that they regard as particularly
outrageous in which they wish which they
wish to stop that's what we mean by
invasion of privacy that is uses of
information about us that we really
don't like but at the same time there
are other kinds of forms of collection
use of personal information that most
people probably are grateful for the
people want access to their social
security funds or their or they want
credit when they need it most so there's
a lot of ambivalence in
in public opinion and our own minds
about the the essential goods and Bad's
and you know what what what really what
the essential evils are and the abuse of
personal information it's hard to come
up with a overall it's hard to come up
with an overall stance about you know
what is what is essentially disturbing
about these trends and and what we can
do what might plausibly be done to to to
turn them around or to to make them more
acceptable part of this part of the
ambiguity about these things I think
stems from bad thinking about where the
trends come from and I hear you know all
kinds of things that seem to me like
funny ideas even from people who know
better people often talk about
technology with a capital some kind of
imaginary capital T as though the
computer or some other complex of
scientifically based tools have acting
on their own somehow gathered personal
information and spirited away like the
invasion of the Body Snatchers or
something like that and some sort of
disembodied dialectic of of
technological supremacy over human will
but in fact although clearly the the
uses and misuses of personal data that
disturbed people these days are
typically perpetrated by computing the
kinds of the trends that lead that have
led to these developments that that
alarm people and which have formed the
occasion for privacy codes around the
world really were well underway long
before computing was a reality the the
idea that big organizations of all kinds
both government and private could could
and should collect as much personal
information as they could to make better
decisions about people then and mobilize
those data to
to make and enforce forceful decisions
about the people concern that idea was
was aborning well into the early 20th
century even in the late 19th century
and the earliest earliest manifestations
of the welfare state
conscription passport issuance the
earliest forms of consumer credit
reporting which i think is one of the
most fascinating and several kinds of
surveillance that one finds anywhere in
the world as it's practiced in America
today had their origins in American
retailing back in the nineteen teens and
20s as far as I can tell well before
anybody had had come up with an idea of
a machine that would make it so much
more easy to so much easier to collect
and disseminate and mobilize that kind
of information so it won't do to blame
the computer I'm not sure if there's any
person to blame but the phenomenon that
I'm describing and that I think that
people react to in the world of the
Privacy Protection and the world of
people who I call privacy Watchers who
are engaged in one way or another of
monitoring these processes and trying to
respond to them these processes that
have set all this in motion have
something to do with the the stance of
institutions and government and the
private industry to dealing with large
numbers of people on the basis of the
precise detail of their records and that
was being done even before people even
just say it one more time even before
computing became the preferred means of
of carrying out these things and the
expectation that that people will have
record that we all have records and that
that the way that we get treated will be
mediated by our records it goes very
very deep even among sort of privacy
sensitive people like me and indeed if
you're dealing with the American Express
or your bank or the IRS or the Social
Security or or even the Department of
Homeland Security if you're having
trouble getting on airplanes as people
often do these days
is because of their records they say
well look you know I'm sure my rent we
say they say we say you know I'm sure my
record is in order II look at look at
the record you know it says here bla bla
that means you've got to do this
it's absolutely part of our cultural DNA
that we we expect to have records and we
expect the treatment that we get from
big institutions to be predicated on
those records of course if things go
wrong that's an invasion of privacy but
if they're not going right to our
satisfaction then maybe that means that
somebody hasn't done their
record-keeping thoroughly enough or he's
not the way that we wanted want it to be
so systems of this kind evoke I think
quite properly very very different in
ambivalent reactions of contradiction
reactions and ambivalent reactions even
within single people even within the
same person and systems that are set up
to do things that almost everybody would
like to see done also very easily could
have the nastiest kinds of implications
that hardly anybody would speak up for
you may have heard or maybe not it's not
such a high-profile thing there's a
program is afoot in the federal
government here in this country to
create a single computerized medical
file for every individual this is being
done with government assistance as a
Bush administration initiative but it
you could imagine it's being hatched by
any presidential administration and the
idea is seemed impeccably reasonable in
its first premise and that is that a lot
of medical mayhem happens because of
ignorance I think you if you take an ill
suddenly or if you're unconscious
terrible things can happen to you that
could easily have been averted if people
had simply been able to get their hands
on your full medical history and it's
not just that if so so if only everybody
could have their all of their medical
data in a single secure place the idea
is then whatever
every place that gives medical care
would have and will have because this
project is likely to bear fruition will
with the course with proper safeguards
we here will gain access to the exact
detail that they need to know about
every person so that every each and
every one of us gets the treatment that
we need when we need it the most and not
only that it obviously once a system
like this is compiled if you subtract
all the all the personal information you
could still notice trends and disease
you could do all kinds of
epidemiological studies that would tell
who you know what kinds of lifestyles or
what sorts of medical histories are
associated with what kinds of
complications or drug reactions or
histories of disease because all kinds
of wonderful things could then
presumably will ensue from a system like
this once it's created as you can tell
I'm not very optimistic with any other
outcome than then it's being graded but
think of what that will mean it will
mean the sheer knowledge that that
everybody's data are there everybody's
complete medical record are there in a
single place we'll make that medical
file like your IRS return and of course
your IRS return has to be provided for
lots of purposes besides the IRS you
can't apply for a mortgage you can't get
your children's financial aid
straightened out at college you can't do
any number of things without providing
providing a doodyville compulsion a copy
of yours of your tax return so one has
to ask you know what other purposes are
going to be served by the compendium of
medical data that people are now
creating well if it's there at subject
to subpoena we know that can you imagine
that the Department of Homeland Security
would be excluded from access what if
the you know what if there was the
possibility of tracking down terrorists
through some detail of their of their
medical their medical data
it's what we see in the growth of
systems like this is a is a process that
goes on it seems to me in in parallel
fashion whether whether within
government or in in private industry it
there it's as though there were a kind
of inner logic of compilation and use of
personal information that leads to
excruciating choices that nobody ever
often seems to have thought of at the
onset of the systems it's difficult to
very difficult to cope with
dispassionately once the data are there
and ready for use one and just to make
just to make these processes more
compelling and intriguing and in my mind
more disturbing they they involve they
include sim fusions let us say between
different kinds of systems so that
information the systems that generate
data for people for one purpose turn out
unexpectedly to prove to be
extraordinarily useful for other
purposes that no one contemplated in
America these days since about 1990 well
let me let me step back all of us have a
credit rating all of us have a number
that reflects our overall desirability
as credit customer credit customers and
that credit rating is used obviously to
evaluate credit reports and to give more
credit it's based on obviously how well
one is paid one's credit obligations and
past but also other things like what I
mentioned the beginning that the amount
of credit available in one's existing
credit accounts not all countries that
not all consumer societies permit this
kind of surveillance this is one thing
that comes out in the book it in detail
France and Australia have what seemed to
me perfectly adequate systems of
allocation of consumer credit that don't
involve this constant monitoring of
people's good good accounts but some
genius in the credit industry
in the late 80s or early 90s came up
with an idea maybe people's credit
ratings would also predict the
experience of insurance companies and
allocating insurance and so the credit
industry began to pitch their scores the
the sale of their credit scores to
insurance companies as a way of
screening insurance applications and the
the qme and according to experience
within the industries they were right to
the delight I'm sure of the entrepreneur
and the credit reporting industry who
thought this up and so this is now
another market for credit reports and it
means in effect that people who have bad
credit are likely to have more trouble
getting coverage for auto or homeowners
insurance than they would do before this
this form of exchange took place and in
addition these fusions of of information
systems cross the boundaries of
government and private institutions so
we know we don't know the details but we
do know that the Department of Homeland
Security is very interested in reports
that cannot be purchased on the market
that are generated by the credit
reporting industry the insurance
reporting industry and and other private
sector retailers of personal data
activities that are now of course much
easier since the sources of such data
credit records county court records
records of insurance experience are all
almost universally compiled on the
computer and hence easily harvested and
and and resold for for profit if I had
one bottom line message about the kind
of analysis of the historical trend to
give from the book is it would be the
following and I know this line very well
because you have to learn it in order to
get your book sold in the first place if
you've ever had anything to do with
publishing they always ask you for what
they call the elevator version of your
book that is the
version of it that can be told while the
editor is passing from one floor to
another in an elevator but no longer
than that so I guess the elevator
message for this book is that there's no
natural limit to these trends in other
words there's no form of personal
information there's no juncture of life
there's no corner of existence that's
inherently - so private or so intimate
that it can't profitably be used for
some useful institutional purpose either
by government organizations or by the
private sector and so accordingly the
only my my conclusion and not mine alone
the only possibility for limiting the
the endless propensity to collect more
data about more areas of life and to
share it more widely and more
resourcefully across different
constituency different institutional
constituencies is some human-made limit
some principle that can be invoked - -
to just say no as they like to say -
attractive but unfortunately excessive
uses of personal data and that's very
hard to do it's there are cases where
the arguments against creating and using
certain forms of data are absolutely
compelling if you you know given your
given a particular view of the political
world for example it seems to me
perfectly reasonable to say that there
ought to be limits on the collection of
data for homeland security purposes such
that not every datum about us that could
conceivably be created is is is
susceptible to be being used for those
purposes it seems to me that it would be
perfectly reasonable to say that the IRS
ought not to have access to the records
of our supermarket purchases or or our
website visits although many people
would argue in a different way but
and and we make those judgments or I
make them and I'm sure that you all
everybody makes them in his or her own
terms in turn in terms of some kind of
calculus about how much you trust the
institutions that that are using the
data and what you know what the possible
repercussions could be if those uses
went wrong but in a way those decisions
contentious as they are and difficult as
it would be even among less I'm sure to
decide you know to to decide how much
information is enough for the Homeland
Security and how much is too much there
are there are still more subtle
questions for which I which I think
perplexed all of us thinking of a an
event that happened in actually here in
California in Northern California two
years ago a little town called Sutter
where the school system decided I think
in late 2005 that each of its pupils in
the elementary school should wear a
computerized tag with an RFID chip that
would track the movement of the of the
pupils on the school premises during the
school day this this was put forward as
a way of vastly simplifying attendance
taking I presume that was also aimed at
curtailing those favorite youthful
patterns of past times of staying in the
bathroom during boring classes and going
out behind the backstop you know when
you were supposed to be listening to
hygiene lectures or something like that
and it would have been very effective
but it's the pupils didn't like it and
the parents didn't like it and there was
an enormous there was an enormous plan
in this case with with good outcomes for
privacy and the school board backed down
on the on the RFID chip idea one of the
parents and one of the public meetings
came up with a great line RFID chips are
mainly used these days as a way of
tracking merchandise in big enterprises
like Walmart where they have a lot of
stuff moving around and concerns about
thievery from em shoplifting and all
that
thing and one of the parents said in one
of the school board meeting our children
are not merchandise than that that
sentiment seemed to carry the day and
the idea was withdrawn it turned out
that this was a the the system was a
gift from the software developer we have
to live in the school district who
wanted to use the district as a kind of
pilot project to promote the idea but I
notice in a story just a month or so ago
that a British school system has now has
now taken up a similar idea the idea
that every child should wear a sweater
or a shirt with an RFID chip involved in
bedded in it throughout the school day
and I hear no reports of any groundswell
of public indignation in that in that
setting saying Britain is much more
amenable to these things I think even
than the u.s. it has more than a million
video cameras in in public places and
numbers growing all the time so I
wouldn't predict that I wouldn't predict
that similar response will occur in the
British case and it could be you know by
the time our children are sending their
children to school that RFID chips are
more the rule than the exception
ultimately I think the strongest argues
so and and so what is what you know why
do we object to this I mean after all
isn't it the duty of schools to protect
their children haven't we always
expected teachers and principals and
head masters and mistresses to keep
track of who's in class and who's not
and and if we do expect that then why is
it wrong to do it better
well why because we don't want to live
in that kind of world I think and most
of us don't
but the incremental nature of the of the
changes the fact that these developments
come step by step in very small doses
and and the habituation to these
developments seems to have a kind of
inoculating effect on our against our
cultural immune systems makes it it
makes it very difficult to draw a
right line against the the accretion of
these kinds of activities and the aim
often is of course a more secure more
convenient more smoothly operating world
but the price ultimately is the world in
which privacy is we used to know it
becomes a kind of sentimental
anachronism and I promised myself that I
wasn't going to read from the book I'm
almost not but I with I just want to
leave you with the last couple of
paragraphs people think people talk
about protecting privacy they
contemplate things that might or might
not be done to keep more data more
personal data in the control of the
people to whom it refers as though it
were an extremely technologically
difficult or or administratively complex
thing and actually I don't believe that
I believe that there there are enormous
ly feasible things that we could do to
restrict the flow of information about
ourselves the problem is that they're
excruciatingly that they're not that
they're complex but that the they
involve interfering with things that we
expect institutions to do so I say at
the end of the book taking such efforts
seriously taking privacy protection
seriously requires that we resolve to
leave some forms of control over human
affairs untried some kids will wander
off from class and perhaps never be seen
again
these things happen such renunciation
runs against the grain of some very deep
public expectations but then so does the
destruction of privacy no one really
wants to live in a world where all
recordable personal information is
effort leaked app tchard and shared
among every and all established
institutions even the promise of total
security and efficiency I believe would
not for most of us make such a world
worth the bargain I've tried to show
that that's exactly the sort of bargain
that we have to contemplate and then
quote Karl Popper the philosopher
institutions wrote popper are like
fortresses they
must be both well-designed and well
defended privacy protection institutions
are just a perfect example of this
without an unsentimental vision of the
pressures on privacy and the political
will to confront those pressures the
most ingenious legislation in
policymaking will avail little it is not
easy to opt for a Messier less efficient
more dangerous and unpredictable world
as the price of authentic privacy but
the alternative is intimately worse so
I've been asked when there are four
questions for people to use the mic at
the center so that all goes on the
record I I can assume that the these
records are going to be kept forever in
some archive and I'm making a clean
breast of it and I guess you can do so
as well
did could you could you use the mic my
question generally goes has to do with
our the existence of a standard by which
or standard by which are some by which
limits should be set or or how how
social limits to decide I'd give you an
example if you take an example would be
with medical records that you spoke
about yeah but I think it's gonna he per
something it's called and it's basically
standard by which our records could be
about by which arm I access is gained to
personal medical records if you look in
most other most other industries or most
other government institution something
there's no existing standard and it's
very difficult to discuss them it's
across across different into across
different our factors the when there's a
big scandal like when there was a story
about the credit card in this company
that had records stolen then there was a
huge gathering or I can maybe a Congress
holder hearing something like that but
then what combo happens is you never
find you find out that there's no sort
of agreement on what should be done and
so my question goes have what is to what
extent have used have you seen have you
studied or are you aware of the
possibility of setting some kind of
common common standards so that people
can begin to UM to use these standards
yeah well it's very important that that
there be a kind of common privacy code
that people can appeal to and in some
sense there is you know the privacy
protection movement if you call it that
is a global movement and they're you
know there is a kind of consensus set of
principles that have to
do with what you might call due process
in the in the treatment of people's
personal data and so in country after
country the guided by these codes there
are there is legislation and policy to
say you know people ought to be able to
find out what's in their own records
they ought to be able to correct
erroneous information they ought to be
able to take exception to unjust
decision making based on the records and
these codes certainly do serve to open
up the processes to the people concern
but they don't necessarily specify what
should be considered proper and improper
forms of access so that's why the idea
of a national pool of medical
information strikes me is so tantalizing
and so worrisome ultimately because one
can imagine all kinds of technological
and procedural safeguards so that
capricious and sadistic individuals
don't find out about somebody else's
records but what will be the position of
when the courts subpoena some records
you know or what you know can can what
imagine that the Department of Homeland
Security or the FBI would be unable if
they produced if they claim compelling
interest to to access such data we know
it's interesting we you know we've all
lived through the birth of whole new
categories of personal information that
it can be very volatile like cell phone
data people tell me that every cell
phone service provider now has a whole
legal department who's whose whose main
responsibility is to respond to both
criminal and civil subpoenas for
information about who was talking to
whom and where so in divorce actions it
becomes very important you know he said
he was on business in Chicago but his
cell phone records say that he was on
vacation in San Diego or something like
that I mean these once
information exists and is known to exist
as many news stories remind us then it
becomes almost impossible not to yes
[Music]
person where you never know which of
your friends it was betraying you and
how all this information goes out to
preserving the genealogists in Salt Lake
City the woman that enormous madam
commissioner curricular power and
nowhere petroleum
well it's very wide suite in the Second
World War in England that was the case
we all of us had to carry ID consoles I
anyway yes well actually there are
things that one could do there are steps
that one could take to change the
balance of power over personal
information and I try to entertain a few
of them in the book I think it'd be a
terrific idea if there were such a thing
as property rights over the commercial
exploitation of data about oneself so
that you would own the right to make
money off of information about you about
yourself much as you could own the
mineral rights to your real property or
to the rights to performance of a song
that you've written or something like
that that idea is is not complicated it
would it would just stop whole
industries in its tracks because then
the credit and insurance reporting
industries would be in a position of
having to pay for what they now get for
free and some people wouldn't wouldn't
want to sell at any price but it's not
that's not complicated it's just because
I say excruciating there are privacy
codes that would if consistently applied
redress a lot of anxieties of the kind
that you describe but they typically
have not been understood to imply to
apply to organisations and the sort of
coercive side of the state like the FBI
the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco Firearms
of homeland security all of the people
who whose activities we worry most about
and know the least about
could you would you like to use the mic
Karthik you don't address the question
about these massive data banks being
totally under Eid stuffed with
misinformation information that comes
from identity theft and from sheer error
so what's the chance of our being able
to exercise our own will and getting
pieces removed from the record because
we say they're wrong or just because we
say so what what what kind of control do
we have well there are some controls
with regard to credit and I believe also
with regard to insurance records the
institutions that hold those records are
supposed to provide you with copies and
they're supposed to respond if you find
something there that's improper a
contextual or simply wrong excuse me of
course it doesn't always work and the
law in the case of credit reporting
which is the one I know better is
written in such a way that the credit
card company has to be satisfied that
you're right in order to correct
something the burden of proof really
lies with you and if they're not
satisfied you you're permitted to enter
us a statement on your credit record
saying this is nonsense and don't
believe it but then the consumer report
has to compare your statement with this
the credit report that they're seeing in
it if you're not satisfied with that
solution then you've got to got to get
private representation and bring legal
action privately against the credit card
company which of course are the credit
reporting agency which is hard to do
there have been some stiff fines levied
against credit reporting agencies when
they've refused in a irresponsible and
refractory way to to respond to
legitimate complaints but most people
don't get that far I'm sure most people
who don't get a responsive
a helpful response from from the
reporting agency just throw up there
their hands and don't pursue it further
it's very very hard to keep track of the
of the flow of information you know I I
think of myself as more attentive than
most people to these kinds of things but
I'm constantly coming across forms of
information about myself that I didn't
even know were being compiled at the
time it's every this is an interesting
little factoid I probably should have
missions to talk every democracy in the
world except the United States possibly
including Japan has an independent
privacy Ombudsman of some kind and some
of them are more aggressive than others
some of them do a better job of
defending personal interests and one
status and others do but this this
country has forced all complaints by
such agencies by just not having one so
if you have privacy anxieties then I
think this may not be the country for
you James is available to sign books if
anyone would like a copy and thanks for
coming have a good night